[Music]
hey what is up guys i'm kbhd here and
this is the samsung galaxy s9 plus as a
couple days after the announcement we've
had our chance to sort of soak it in and
think about it for a little bit and it's
become pretty clear actually that it
seems like this whole event this
announcement was saved from being called
the exact same phone as last year
by one major feature upgrade
the camera so that's what we're all kind
of looking at right now so while we have
it before it actually comes out let's
take a deeper look at what exactly will
make this phone apparently different
from every other phone out there let's
take a deep look at the camera so the
galaxy s9 has a single 12 megapixel
optically stabilized camera with a
variable aperture and the galaxy s9 plus
we have here has dual cameras so the
same primary camera and an additional
secondary 2x telephoto camera fixed at f
2.4 so the biggest change obviously at
least on paper is that variable aperture
so as i mentioned briefly in my
impressions video of this phone with a
couple exceptions pretty much every
single smartphone camera out there is a
fixed aperture lens which means the
aperture doesn't change it doesn't open
or close they're letting in a certain
amount of light every time to hit that
sensor and most new phones are around f
2.0 sometimes f 1.9 or f 1.8 pixel 2 one
of the best smartphone cameras ever has
a fixed f 1.8 aperture lens so the
galaxy s9 has this dual aperture lens it
can physically switch between
f 1.5
wide open which is incredible or f 2.4
depending on how much light is in this
scene so basically it'll shoot almost
everything at f 2.4 by default in auto
but when you get down to about 100 lux
samsung says which is actually pretty
low light it'll open up wide to f 1.5
but if you ever actually want to make
sure you're using one aperture or the
other you can go into pro mode and that
is where one of the toggles is 1.5 or
2.4 now as far as the difference between
the photos i'm still evaluating that but
i have started taking back to back
photos with the f15 and f24 and i've
shared some on twitter already so you
can make that call if you see a
difference right now i think showing
them back to back is what makes it more
obvious but the full analysis will be in
the review for sure so that is a pretty
promising new development with the
camera that we're messing with but it's
definitely not all that's new also new
in the camera is an improved composite
hdr mode so it's now taking 12 frames
and turning in photos with great dynamic
range and reduced noise and better
contrast that's all on auto hdr though
so you don't have to do anything special
for that there's also the whole new
sliding ui of the camera kind of like
what we've been seeing in the iphone for
years i think it's definitely an
improvement it kind of encourages you to
swipe around and explore all the
different modes that you might not have
even known have existed in the samsung
camera app for years and one of the most
important ones is of course this pro
mode not a whole ton to say about it
other than it keeps getting better you
can change pretty much everything here
so if you're into photography you know
your shutter speed iso manual focus
white balance and even of course that
toggle for switching manually between
f15 and f24 that's what i've been using
to take the back to back comparison
shots but also new with the camera is
this super slow motion video mode now if
you jump into the camera settings
there's actually already a ton of video
frame rates to choose from you can shoot
at 4k 30 or 4k 60 frames per second you
can shoot quad hd or 1080p even super
widescreen at 18 and a half by nine and
there's also a high efficiency video
codec you can toggle on or off and you
might have also heard about 1080p at 240
frames per second but that's actually
hidden by default it's strangely
difficult to find you have to go into
the camera settings edit camera modes
and then the rear camera and then you
gotta tick regular slow motion for some
reason it's unchecked and hidden by
default on mine but when you do that's
where the 1080p 240fps is the more you
know but what we're really interested in
of course is that new
960 frames per second at 720p other
phones have done this there's been so
many phones to do near 1000 frames a
second but this is new to samsung so
this will turn a 0.2 second video clip
into a six second smooth video
also it will only record for 0.2 seconds
so here's how it works first of all it
crops in a lot so you're gonna have to
back up for your framing be prepared for
that and then there's two ways to do it
manually or automatically
because it's super hard to time
something that's that fast to press the
shutter button at the exact right moment
and you can try and that's what the
manual mode is for but that might take a
while to get the perfect action but the
automatic mode is pretty cool it puts a
box on the screen that you can move
around and then you hit start and it'll
wait until something some movement
enters that box to trigger the super
slow motion so you can get some pretty
cool clips if you place the box
perfectly where you expect the action to
happen it's not bad all right next up in
the camera is something called ar emoji
i like i said in that impressions video
it's basically an emoji but not as good
this one relies entirely on the
front-facing camera no extra depth
sensors or anything like that and it's
closer to like snapchat's bitmoji than
anything else but it's still worse than
that so you take a picture of yourself
and it analyzes it for like a minute or
so and then turns you into a sort of a
animated character and then you can
further customize your character to look
just like you kinda unless they don't
have your hair
and then you have your ar emoji it's
pretty creepy if i'm i'm being honest
but i i didn't actually appreciate how
smooth and accurate apple's animoji was
until i went back after this and tried
it again and it's like way better but i
don't see many people using ar emoji
past the first few days or two maybe
just for fun but you know here it is it
exists now so the last thing that's new
with this camera is bixby vision so yes
bixby is still a big part of samsung's
efforts but also bixby vision can
probably be pushed in a software update
to other things like the note and the s8
but this is what's new with that you go
into the camera app and you see this
little eye you click the i and it'll go
into this sort of recognition mode where
it can offer a couple different things
qr codes those are pretty
self-explanatory it'll read those
wines will literally read wine bottles
and tell you more about them very
specific
places will identify where you're at and
you can look around sort of find nearby
places and landmarks and then shopping
will try to identify a product by
related product shots it finds on the
internet and then lets you maybe buy
them
images just tries to reverse image
search whatever you're looking at to
find out what it is so the closest thing
to what you're looking at on google
images text is pretty interesting it
uses google translate and will live
translate any text in front of you which
could actually be helpful in real life
and the makeup section which uh just
switches to the front facing camera and
puts makeup on you lets you try a bunch
of different products and then gives you
a link to buy them directly and that's
it that is everything that is new with
the galaxy s9 camera and the s9 plus uh
it still has all the old stuff it still
has live focus with the dual cameras for
taking portrait mode shots still has
some of the stickers and things
but that's that's your camera reimagine
now this isn't the full review of the
whole phone so we'll wait till then to
put conclusions on everything and see if
it's actually worth it all but you can
probably come to a lot of conclusions
yourself i mean looking at sample photos
we already know this is going to be one
of the top smartphone cameras of this
year it's just a matter of whether it
falls at number one or number two or
number three
but stay tuned to places like twitter
and instagram where i'll be posting
sample photos as i take them and as i
use this phone more coming up to the
full review but until then
thanks for watching
talk to you in the next one
peace